finely neural if Russia is going to keep
attacking America then America really
should fight back the conventional
wisdom is that in the 1980s st. Ronald
Reagan defeated the Soviet did the
Soviet you you know and then the Berlin
Wall came down and everybody was friends
but what really happened was we stopped
fighting the Cold War but the Russians
never did they may have changed the name
of the KGB the way Kentucky Fried
Chicken became KFC but trust me their
boast a lot they're poisoning people
there is an entire building in st.
Petersburg filled with a Russian troll
army hundreds of employees of their
defense department sitting in front of
computers pretending to be Americans and
creating thousands of tweets memes news
site comments and flat-out fake stories
designed not to take sides on any issue
but just to get us fighting about it to
create chaos the better to elect the
chaos candidate here's an example of a
Russian created meme from 2016 it says
up to 5.7 million illegals may have
voted in 2008 election well that of
course is ridiculous but it nevertheless
reached 10 million American voters by
way of Facebook millions more through
Twitter and one guy on Bain
Hilary Clinton spent over a billion
dollars on the campaign and the Russians
beat her with a hundred and fifty grand
because they were able to turn Facebook
into fakebook or a more apt name might
be [ __ ] starter because that's what they
were doing that's what their meddling
was meant to do start [ __ ] and boy was
that easy to do since Facebook is the
place we're thinking when to die
[Applause]
all the time people used to just waste
reading books and newspapers well now
they're sharing share he's that great
that we all share Putin thinks it's
great that's why he only had to spend
150 grand because we spread his
propaganda for him and it really bugs me
that Facebook took that word and
rat-fucked it sharing as I recall it
meant actually giving something of yours
away to another another kid forgot his
lunch
you gave him half of yours sharing but
how is it sharing to send me a picture
of your lunch that's just saying I've
got food and you Jones
[Applause]
Facebook sharing isn't sharing it's
mostly humble bragging up so embarrassed
didn't realize there was a hole in the
knee of my jeans and now my penis was
showing it's a lot of that [ __ ] and
it's a healthy amount of here's
something I want you to know I have for
something called sharing there's an
awful lot of look at me look how
talented my kids are look what great
concert seats I have look I'm in Italy
and urine Pacoima and the Russians saw
this and they took our everyone needs to
smell my every brain fart culture and
used it as the engine for spreading
their [ __ ] for the purpose of
starting cockfights except we're the
[ __ ] we're the brainless birds pecking
at each other
that's what Putin knew that was social
media it would be easy to get America to
start cockfighting he just made sure the
tiniest [ __ ] one